hello everyone and welcome to the world
blitz championship the world rabbit
championship ended with Magnus Carlsen
clinching first place with a full point
ahead of everyone else and now it's time
for two days of blitz we're not gonna be
covering a lot of games like we did in
the rapid section since it would be
impossible the Blitz game it just
happened too fast but if I see any I
like I'm definitely gonna show them and
of course do use hashtag suggestion at
inform you of any other nice games that
were played so this is a game from round
through to both of them won their games
in round one it's Magnus Carlsen versus
a Russian Grand Master Vladimir belif
and well let's check it out Magnus with
the white pieces opens with E for we're
c6 d4 and d5 the Carl Khan is on the
board and here
Magnus not interested in finding out the
Russian grandmasters preparation in the
caro-kann just goes for the exchange
variation with each capture C captures
something that we would very it's not
very likely that we would see this in a
classical game for example Bishop d3
Knight to c6 we have c3 strengthening
the center Knight of 6 and Bishop to f4
Magnus goes for the Rubinstein variation
we have Bishop to g4 attacking the Queen
and Queen to b3 now putting pressure on
b7
Queen to d7 defending and now Knight to
d2 yeah we have east 6 closing the
structure now that the light square
bishop has been developed preparing to
develop the dark square bishop as well
Knight G to f3 and Bishop to d6 now
offering a trade now for those who
perhaps don't know these are three
minutes in the three minute games and
you have a 2 2 seconds increment so 95
sticking a knight and nicely in the
center of the board and Queen to c7 now
getting the Queen out way and also
putting pressure if you move the knight
you could lose the bishop on f4 and
while Magnus could go for Knight
captures ng4 he prefers to keep the
tension with castles bell of also
castles and here a rook 81 so just you
know mobilizing pieces Bishop to h5
getting the bishop out of harm's way and
now butter up the g3 now the knight can
move and the bishop is nicely protected
Bishop to g6 and here Magnus grabs
night cap tristan g 6h captures and the
other night now comes to f3 and here
there is a game from 1966 it was played
by nicholas Rosalie Moe himself he
played against Eduardo Perez where Perez
played at the shop characters ng3 and
Rafa Lehman was able to win this game
but rook eight abbi eight in this game
and it is a sum of fifteen that we have
a completely new game so Magnus decides
that this game is not going to take
place on the queenside
he transfers the Queen over to the Kings
side we have Queen c2 rook F the c8 bill
of doesn't agree he wishes to play on
the Queen side and Queen to eat you now
we have Knight to e7 and now Bishop
captures on d6 we have Queen captures
and now sticking the other knights to e5
and now you could challenge it with
Knight to c6 Magnus would play f4 again
keeping it there if you capture then you
get F captures you're gonna be F file to
you to be used for for rooks so Knights
the f5 and the Magnus doesn't appreciate
this night here so he just kicks it back
with g4 9 back to e7 and F for now now
cementing this night in the center of
the board with a six bail of now wants
to push b5 in B fort at the bust open
the Queen side and the make use of his
two rooks and here Carlson has to decide
whether he wants them go for a queen g2
and f5 or keeper or perhaps he wants to
go for a rook F 3 H 3 and maybe put a
queen on h4 maybe try and checkmate the
black king Magnus prefers the queen g2
idea with b5 bail of continues playing
on the Queen side and now as Peter like
I said it's it's mating time so f5 so
what do you do here with E e captures on
f5 we have G captures an f5 Knight
captures Bishop captures pawn captures
and rook captures so all the captures
were were necessary and now before
continuing to play on the Queen Queen
side although this was perhaps a bit too
optimistic maybe just a nice defensive
move would have been better rugby 6
getting the roof to help out with the
defense of the Kings side ok it's a
blitz game bellow pushes before and now
rook eat the f1 already with the threat
of rook captures on f6 since the
one would be pinned King 2f8 unpinning
but now rook to g5 putting pressure on
g7 and there's no good way to defend the
pawn for example if you push it you and
Magnus can just capture it and after
pawn captures Queen captures there's the
threat of mate and also there's just the
threat of rogue captures which wins the
Queen and also meets fairly quickly
so definitely mating time with B
captures and c3 instead and Magnus just
goes for it rook captures and g7 C
capture son b2 and rook captures on f7
width check now King Teti 8 and here you
can continue this game in a lot of ways
but the quickest one the one Magnus
chose well quickest is Queen to g7 but
Magnus decided to go for Queen to g6
threatening a lot of nasty discoveries
here and it was in this position unmoved
31 that Vladimir belf resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
point being that if you for example
bring your Queen into the game then it's
just rook f8 check you clear the f7
square for your queen it's a double
check from the Queen and the rook so you
have the capture and then just Queen f7
mate for example or after Queen to g6
you could try running away King to date
but then it's just rook 7 captures on f6
the Queen is under attack and whatever
let's say you move the Queen then it's
well rook f8 check King has the move
came to c7 for example and now Queen to
c6 is mate so a lot of very interesting
checkmates and well magnus wins his
around 2 game against Russian Grand
Master Vladimir bell so a pretty clean
game and as you see it's not very often
that we will see an exchange in the
caro-kann sense it's considered that
white just doesn't get all that much out
of the opening but for blitz
anything goes especially for Magnus so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
we're not gonna be covering all that
many games like I said too many of them
are being played too fast and if one
really you know presents itself that it
should be shown we're gonna show it and
do use hashtag suggestion if you have if
you're you know watching one of your
favorites and it turns out to be a
beauty so I would like to thank dolly
buddy I clean for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and
I will see soon continuing the coverage
of the world blitz championship thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your Sunday